so it turns out that trashy reality
dating tv shows
also work on the internet usually i'm
treated like a rose but when i dated
hassan i was treated like a cactus
because i was so it was so dry so often
it was terrible
tactics are full of full of juices
though but a recent twitch dating show
that tried to cash in on this trend
turned out to be completely fake fake
contestants
fake host fake location all organized by
a dude
with a fake name and the strangest part
is
it almost worked
alright okay okay okay let's do this you
know the drill
scroll down hit the subscribe button
it'll make me happy while you're at it
hit that notification bell you'll never
miss a thing
ever again over the last few years
dating shows have become
extremely popular in the just chatting
category of twitch
thanks in large part to the austin show
which was formerly known as the raj
patel show on one of his most popular
shows lover host
a bunch of streamers are thrown together
in an attempt to win the affection of
that day's digital bachelor or
bachelorette
while in some cases also becoming twitch
famous in the process
and one of the side effects of these
shows are streamers using them as a
platform to gain more and more clout
hassan sakuno and destiny are just a few
of the names who've appeared on one of
austin's shows
now a more recent attempt to cash in on
this dating show trend
was a project called twitch's most
eligible essentially
it was trying to rip off lover host in
real life
instead of having contestants battle it
out for one person's attention on stream
twitch's most eligible pledged to fly
out small streamers
to stay in a mansion and stream a
bachelor-style twitch show on location
all expenses paid by the way the only
problem was everything was fake
and we know everything was fake due to
twitch streamers like bx bullet and zach
busey
doing a little bit of digging and
pointing out the very glaring red flags
on twitter
but when she first heard about this
project
bx bullet didn't know what to think so i
decided to follow them on twitter and
just kind of monitor it
and i told them i would just the person
who brought it to me i was like oh i'll
just kind of monitor it and see
it looks like maybe they've got
something planned and it's going to get
pushed back but let's like just wait and
see
um because i didn't have any evidence of
them reaching out to people or anything
like that
okay let's start with the person who
claimed to be the executive producer of
this entire thing
matthew peltier or matt fox
which is the other name that he uses
online matthew peltier apparently works
in email marketing
while matt fox literally the same person
used to run a udemy learning course that
was allegedly fake and a waste of time
according to the only person who
bothered to leave a review
on top of that the url from mattfox.net
redirects to twitch'smostelgible.com
and as zach busey points out on twitter
when matthew peltier poses as matt
fox in his emails he uses a completely
different
photo so you know we're not off to a
great start
i couldn't find anything linked to him
at all except for his linkedin that he
had listed there
and his linkedin only had like 15
connections so
uh i thought that was weird if they were
trying to spin him into being this like
big production network guy with all
these connections and all this money
he sure didn't have any kind of online
presence at all and i thought that was
weird you know if i'd have seen
something that was like oh yeah this
guy's been behind x y and z productions
in the past i'd probably
have let it go all right whatever next
let's talk about the email that was sent
to
hundreds of small streamers the email
includes the same boilerplate text in
each one
and the photo of the woman sending the
emails who goes by britney goode
is allegedly a photo of a bollywood
actress by the name of rashmika mandana
once word of this email reached twitter
dozens and dozens of women
started to come forward to say hey i've
received the exact same one
here's zach busey talking about it on
stream they must have sent this thing to
thousands if not tens of thousands of
people
uh i don't know how they managed to
scrape but i'm sure they did i'm sure
it's pretty easy to just scrape a
profile of an email address
or a twitter account uh especially if
you're an email marketer
there was a whole bunch of people in my
dms going have you heard of this have
you heard of this is this something
twitch is doing and
i'm like no it's a scam it's not
anything
legitimate also shout out to him for
absolutely
grilling eligible's twitter account
which has since been deleted
now in response to a question about who
the hell was funding this enterprise
twitch's most eligible twitter account
responded with
quote it's a hundred percent self-funded
with outside investment by matt's
reality tv
llc which is owned by executive producer
matthew peltier end quote
if you try to find the website for
matt's reality tv
well it looks like this to be honest
from the digging that i've done
it's impossible to find matt's reality
tv anywhere on the internet
from there bx bullet told me that she
actually jumped into twitch's most
eligible discord server
using a secondary profile according to
her what she found were dozens and
dozens of women
all wondering what the hell was going on
now bx bullet says that she spoke to a
mod by the name of
faith curry allegedly this was the same
faith curry that twitch's most
eligible hired as its casting director
and like pretty much everyone else
attached to this project
there's virtually no information about
faith curry online
which led a lot of people to speculate
that she's not
real okay let's quickly run through the
rest of what's either
fake sketchy as hell or just poorly
thought out
first this was supposed to happen during
the middle of a pandemic
according to zack the mansion in the
appalachian mountains that was
advertised was never actually rented for
the time period that the show was
supposed to shoot
and oh yeah one of the bachelors didn't
even know he was being
advertised as a [ __ ] bachelor wings
of death
or daryl said that he told somebody from
twitch's most eligible
team that he didn't want to participate
due to coven
which as far as reasons go is pretty
solid they then asked if they could make
a private profile for him in case he
wanted to come on the show in the future
and he said yeah sure whatever thinking
that the show
probably wasn't going to happen in the
first place so they then made a profile
slapped his face on all of their
marketing announced him as one of the
bachelors
and just didn't tell her and according
to bx bullet once he found that out
he was [ __ ] pissed you could see that
he was really surprised when i brought
up that his profile was still
up and being used to lure people into
the trap
because they were using his clout to
just kind of lure people into thinking
and convince people to think he was
legit and he seemed very concerned
now we do actually have an ending to
this story because
matthew peltier the guy in charge of all
of this
posted a twitlonger on february 15th
attempting to explain
everything he starts out by saying that
neither him nor the team he assembled
were trying to deceive anyone
and that doing an irl version of love or
host just seemed like a fun
project according to him matt fox is an
alias that he used years ago
and that emails were sent out under the
matt fox name because
that email address is used regularly to
send a newsletter out to subscribers
now i have no idea why he's using an
email address for an
alias he used years ago which seemingly
has
nothing to do with this show he says
that yes faith curry is a real person
and that she streams on twitch
but he doesn't link her twitch and i
haven't found anyone resembling the
woman depicted in the photo i showed you
earlier
matthew says that they did get
permission from wings of death to add
him to twitch's most eligibles website
and marketing
but pulled him down as soon as he asked
now remember britney goode the fake
person they used a bollywood actress's
photo for
here's what matthew had to say about
that quote this is an
alias account operated by a staff member
on our team
who did not want her identity revealed
end quote
when it comes to spamming hundreds of
people with that boilerplate email
matthew says that twitch's most eligible
team was working on a tight deadline of
march
9th to get everything finished and so
they weren't careful about who they sent
that email to
now this mass email was sent out around
february 14th
so you're telling me that this dumb irl
dating show was supposed to fly out
women to a remote location
dealing with all of the logistics that
come with that not to mention it's
happening during the middle of a
pandemic
and this was all supposed to come
together in under a month
here's how matthew ends his twit longer
quote i completely understand why people
are skeptical of the show's intentions
given my mistakes in using these fake
email accounts
if we're lying about names then what
else are we lying about
aliases are not cool when you're
representing a company and i should have
known better we take your safety and
security concerns very seriously
even the appearance of impropriety is
unacceptable i've decided to stop the
production of the show effective
immediately while i discuss next steps
among my team
end quote so yeah according to him the
show has been put on hiatus for now
now look an irl dating show is not a bad
idea sticking a bunch of streamers into
a house together would probably make for
good content
[ __ ] i know it would my first episode of
this show
was about the very worst version of that
idea
we haven't even gotten to the dog [ __ ]
yet and yeah there was a dog
and it's [ __ ] everywhere god i was bad
at this anyway you know what
is a terrible idea spending less than a
month on production
faking a bunch of names and emails and
then saying that you're gonna fly a
bunch of women out to a remote location
during the middle of a pandemic so will
we ever see something like this again
honestly probably yeah fake contestants
fake host fake something else
fake contestants fake host fake flash
frames
it's like when you try to put tape
around your head when you're a kid you
ever try to like
[ __ ] wrap scotch tape around your
head maybe it was just me
nope you're not truly
maybe why i didn't have a lot of friends
growing up they just thought it was a
[ __ ] weirdo
i mean they're not wrong but